dillon out for his 20th start that's a
lot at this point era a touch over four
a lot of strikeouts 127 of them and 97
and two thirds with kepler in the box
ready to go
first pitch
and laced into right field base half
well maybe things turn a little bit for
max kepler that's the second time we've
seen him in chicago find that spot right
there on the field
polanco hitting 255. he banged a
go-ahead two-run homer in the eight last
night
popped up this is a long run for tim
anderson and moncada as well tim gets
over again
he's been so good steve from right of
second base scooting over to make the
plan left well the only thing you worry
about here is you worry about a
collision most likely with andrew vaughn
but you see where tim sets up i mean he
is well on the first base side of second
and then he's off to the races he calls
for it right away and when he does that
andrew gives him some room and he makes
the play michael pineda with his first
start tonight in exactly two weeks
pineda has just not thrown that much
since coming off the injured list and
the 1-0 pitch
anderson jam popped it up playable
behind first snow polanco there
and it's polanco and shallow right
calling and catching as miguel cinel
steps in 3-0 count and the pitch is
swinging to smash left side base hit
left field this one towards the corner
but it's cut off by vaughn miguel a wide
turn hangs on and puts on the brakes
that was a rocket left side and he won
out base hit for cino second hit the
twins have against cease tonight
eight home runs 44 knocked in from the
wind up again the 2-2 ground ball
speared by big mike atop the mound
underhand lob to first base for the
first out there you go pineda
good position to make that play
reaching down to his left and he gloved
that ground ball rather casually
and easily
gets the out monkatta retired one out
burger big-time power numbers at aaa
charlotte this year waits for the 2-2
and the pitch he got him strike three
swinging on a breaking ball
and down goes jake burger white sox
don't score twins commit an error but it
leads to nothing after two no score
kepler lead off single to begin the game
driven down the right field line deep to
the corner
and off the foul pole
max kepler hitting his 12th of the year
and the twins strike first
well he likes hitting in this ballpark
and this is almost identical spot to
where he hit the homer the other night
it was singles starting to find some
holes and homer's starting to find their
way over the fence a good sign he starts
swinging that well and back in that lead
off spot kind of setting the tone his
off speed stuff is so slow you just have
to wait wait wait and you see kepler
almost with a little half short swing on
the end of that but
hit it off the sweet spot and
right off the foul pole we'll see how
dillon bounces back here
first strikeout for cease
they're watching again as he drops a
breaking ball and it had the whole zone
it was on the outside corner but plenty
of the plate so you change
velocities within the same pitch
oh a nasty slider donaldson is really
unhappy with himself but he never picked
up the spin on this so to him he
identified it as a fastball and then it
just disappeared
polanco finally takes off swinging and a
miss by larnick he strikes out
kepler with a lead off homer off the
pole in right
and we go to the bottom of the third
it's now minnesota one
the white sox nothing and here is billy
hamilton you don't need to hit on 700
feet there's a ground ball past
donaldson into left
hamilton loses his helmet and he's going
to have a double
as larnett picked up that ball and he
had no chance anyway
but his right foot gave way
and larnick will lob it back in toward
third
hamilton runs tim swings through it and
that's a stolen base for billy hamilton
his hat became a ground ball
his body became 90 feet away from the
tying run
picked a good pitch and jeffers could
not get the hand up
even if he catches it cleanly it's going
to be a tough throw to make he had speed
at first speed at third a batter that
can to put the bat on the ball two and
two
on the ground third base side it gets to
simmons he's got no play anywhere
now donaldson went after the ball
simmons was thinking about third but
there was nobody home and we're tied
this is another slider
you see almost a half swing as he's
trying to put the ball in play and it
turns into gold
donaldson deflects it but simmons with
no play that's about as well placed as
you can get garcia the batter he reached
on an error
garcia is on his way to second and this
is an easy double with two out for laori
garcia
long pause and the pitch
swung out hit into left center fielded
fairly well gordon there as he dives for
it and comes up with it nice play
by nick gordon out in center field
so pineda pitches out of a two-out jam
leaves a runner at second base four in
the books polanco putting together now
with the
increased batting average clutch home
runs
and just enough launch angle
to get it out of garcia's reach two out
single will get cruz to the plate nelly
to battle for two
and hit the right field hit fairly well
long-running engel tracking tracking
can't come up with it's gonna one hop
into the seats
if that ball stays in play polanco
scores easily
base hitch his score two and a one-o
pitch ground ball up the middle it's
gonna be a base hit
one run in
nelson cruz being waved around here
comes hamilton's throw not in time and
the twins now lead three to one
for two tonight
and softly in the center and it may stop
rolling before hamilton gets there picks
it up with his bare hand but it works
two out single not hitting jorge blanco
to the plate
a drive to right field and deep angle
back and it's gone polanco
delivers again just incredible he's been
so good with runners in scoring position
and
takes a 3-0 pitch gets almost an
identical pitch three and one but stays
through it and twins increase their lead
and this is just got a lot more
comfortable and backing up pineda solid
start this one actually looks like it
might have been even possibly even lower
than the pitch before but
look at that swing just strong hands
gets the barrel and whips it through and
nice catch by duffy in the whole thing
the kick in the 1-0
short fly left field diving catch andrew
vaughn he continues to impress that's
our defensive play of the game he's done
it again
did everything right on that
one of the things you can't do is come
running in as fast as you can out of
control he came running in under control
and timed that forward dive in a
position where he knew he could make the
grab and maintain control of it when he
landed here's monkatta
2-2
deep drive center field
off the wall
oncotta now racing towards second he'll
stand with a double he just missed the
home run
and rouvon one for three
o2 lined into left center it's going to
roll for a while mankato will score
vaughn on his way to second and he's got
a double
six to two
continue to stay hot
down the line fair into the corner
three straight hits for polanco
and he'll go to second with a double
with one out in the ninth
that'll work
deep to left
and on the warning track caught by
vaughan
and polanco trots home with the seventh
run
anderson's reached his last three times
with a walk double and single and the
3-2 pitcher ground ball left side
simmons has it the second one polanco's
return double play and that's the game
twins win the game 7-2 6-4-3 game ending
innovative office solutions double play
and the twins split the four-game set
win the finale 7-2
in chicago